الدولة التي قدمت
أكبر دعم لأوكرانيا حتى الآن هي
الولايات المتحدة ،
وهذا صحيح بعشرات وعشرات المليارات من
الدولارات.
يأخذ الجمهوريون مجلس
النواب الذي هو
سلطة المحفظة التي أه من حيث
تأتي الأموال ،
هل تقلق من
أن
هذه المساعدة الأمريكية ستتباطأ أو
تتوقف وماذا ستكون رسالتك
إلى جمهوريي المنزل
أولاً وقبل كل شيء؟
أود أن أقول على الفور إنني
ممتن للرئيس بايدن
والبيت الأبيض ودعم الحزبين
لأنك نعم أنت على حق القادة في
حجم وحجم الدعم بدون
هذا الدعم لن نتمكن من
إعادة أراضينا  وأنا أدرك
أنني وأنا صريح تمامًا حول هذا الأمر
وأدرك موقفهم القيادي
في تلك الأمور التي أعرفها
وأسمع الرسائل التي ذكرتها للتو.
قد يحدث ذلك لممثلي الحزب الجمهوري
حتى يدعموا أوكرانيا ، ولكنني أرغب في
تصديق أن دعم الحزبين
سيبقى قويًا وثابتًا بالنسبة لنا ،
وهذا أمر مهم للغاية
لأوكرانيا المضاد قد أعاد تشكيل
ساحة المعركة في غضون أيام
أخذوها  مساحة أكبر في الأسبوع الماضي
من روسيا منذ أبريل ، لذا فإن
السؤال هو كيف فعلوا ذلك ، أريد أن
أحضر نيل ملفين ، وهو مدير
دراسات الأمن الدولي في
المعهد الملكي للخدمات المتحدة ، وهو
مركز أبحاث هنا في لندن الآن ماذا
نحن ننظر هنا إلى خريطة
لما استعادت أوكرانيا هذا القسم
هنا بشكل
أساسي وهي مساحة ضعف مساحة
لندن الكبرى حقًا في الأسبوع الماضي ،
لذا أخبرني كيف فعلوا ذلك ،
نعم ، أعني أنه كان تغييرًا جذريًا
تمامًا  مفاجأة لأن الجميع
كان يركز على الجنوب أه
هنا حول الحصن حيث
تحدثنا من قبل عن الضغط الذي تمارسه أوكرانيا
هنا وأن هذا
كما اتضح كان
استراتيجية متعمدة لمحاولة سحب الروس
بعيدًا عن الشمال ، ثم
وجد الأوكرانيون فجوة في الخطوط الروسية
ودفعوا هنا بسرعة كبيرة
، لقد تحركوا بسرعة كبيرة
خلف الروس وانهارت الجبهة الروسية
، وبالتالي عادت هذه المنطقة
الآن إلى السيطرة الأوكرانية
وما زلنا نسمع
أنهم مستمرون في اتخاذ
التسويات حيث تعتقد أن
نوع التحركات الهجومية التالية جيدًا
التحدي بالنسبة لروسيا الآن هو أن
خطهم الأمامي قد انهار ، لذا فإن
قواتهم تتراجع في كثير من الأحيان في حالة من الفوضى التي
يحتاجون إليها لمحاولة رسم خط الآن
لوقف الهجوم وأعتقد أن ما يريدون
القيام به هو على الأقل التمسك بهذه المنطقة التي
تسمى لوهانسك  التي تقع في
منطقة دونيتسك الأساسية هذه والتي كانت منطقة
سيطر عليها الروس منذ عام 2014
عندما بدأت الحرب الأولى ،
لا يمكنهم السماح للأوكرانيين بالدخول إلى تلك المنطقة ،
لذا سيحاولون
الانسحاب  إعادة تجميع صفوفهم وسيستمر الأوكرانيون في
التقدم حتى يصلوا إلى خط المواجهة الجديد
وسيحاول الروس الاحتفاظ
بهم هناك
كيف وصلنا إلى النقطة التي
تمكنت فيها أوكرانيا من الوصول
إلى زاوية مثل هذا ، أي نوع من
الاختلاف لديه  الإمداد
الغربي بالأسلحة المصنوع هنا ، أريد تكبير الصورة
أيضًا في هذه المنطقة حتى نتمكن من النظر
إليها جيدًا ، وأعتقد أن ما رأيناه حقًا
هو عدد من الأشياء أولاً وقبل كل شيء ،
ربما لم يكن الهجوم الروسي الأولي
كافياً  الآن نفد
زخمهم ، لقد
نفدوا من القوات التي
نفدوا منها المعدات التي لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها في كثير من الأحيان باستخدام هذه
المدفعية القياسية الجديدة لحلف شمال الأطلسي والصواريخ
التي وصلت إلى الأوكرانيين ،
مما أدى إلى تدمير جميع خطوط الإمداد
بمخزونات  هذه
الأسلحة وهكذا كانت عملية بطيئة جدًا
ثم فجأة سريعة جدًا
حيث ينهار الروس ونفدهم
وهكذا
، وما فعله الأوكرانيون
بشكل فعال للغاية هو أنهم
جمعوا  أجزاء مختلفة من الجيش ،
والقوات الجوية ، والقوات البرية للصواريخ
، وهي تتحرك بسرعة كبيرة حتى
لا يكون لدى الروس ما يكفي من القوات
للسيطرة على هذا الخط الأمامي الطويل جدًا ،
ويتم ضرب الأوكرانيين من خلال ذلك